all right millions of people live every
day with severe pain and it doesn't
matter if you start hurting today or if
you're dealing with an injury from 30
years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method of chiropractic care
can help
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from this
pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife
faye oh it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing tiredness fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak uh she was fine
danuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients uh
young children
um people who've been in bad car
accidents bad falls maybe we've even had
surgery before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day workup day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests
checking every range of motion of their
spine orthopedic neurological test
posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best type of films in our field
i'm going to study those i'm going to
study the notes so day two
we're gonna sit down and i'm gonna go
over the findings and listen if i can't
help someone
i'm gonna let them know and i'm gonna
get them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward
how long is it gonna take what's it
gonna cost what's my insurance due or
not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain i wasn't able to lift
my
arms brush my own hair it's almost like
a relief
when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
normally that two-day work-up
is 180 what we're gonna do for viewers
of the show
is give it to the first 20 callers i
have to limit it
after that it goes up to regular price
for only 37
you heard dr devin the first 20 callers
will only pay
37 for both normally it's 180 dollars
call 702 566 hope or 4673
you can also get more information at
drdevin.com
there's more las vegas now just ahead
we'll be right back